[Music]
foreign
I was given a brilliant present
by a great fan Andres traitikov he gave
me a gallium model inspired by Lego I
suppose of the T1000 Terminator robot I
was quite excited and then Andres said
it might melt in my hand because gallium
has a very low melting point under 30
degrees Centigrade I've been keeping it
in my fridge in my office until Brady
arrived I'm not a great sci-fi fan and
know very little about the Terminator
but I knew it involved molten metal and
liquid nitrogen so Brady and Neil Neil
is a great fan too decided they would
begin with liquid nitrogen pouring
liquid nitrogen over my little
Terminator
foreign
and of course it got cold gallium
doesn't shatter when it gets cold so it
just got cold looked a bit lonely so
Neil decided he would warm it up with a
hair dryer
it was quite an old hairdryer
he tried to dry his hair but there isn't
much in your dreams that on there
there's the there's your target work
better with me and so we started heating
up the little Terminator
[Music]
monster my surprise it appeared to melt
from the bottom even though we were
heating it at the top and I'm still not
entirely sure why
[Music]
there are obviously once liquid metal is
formed it will all pool at the bottom
and perhaps that improves the
conductivity
because the heat is blowing down from
the top
it was quite
an effort for needle to keep
the heat gun going and if you watch it
does sort of drop a little even Neil has
a limit to his strength
anyway
it's slowly melted
and
eventually it was all gone
[Applause]
but Brady felt the brave Professor
should come and Fight The Terminator
so he persuaded me to bring down my
favorite Lego Professor
lamb of the slaughter
I've had it for a long time it's been
blown up with nitrogen Tri iodide and
survived
and it was cooled with liquid nitrogen
nothing happened except it floated
better
than the Terminator
but then Neil got out his torch
[Music]
and the professor disappeared
in the cloud
of smoke and Flames
it was pretty dramatic
but I was left
with a child body
but the great thing about video
is that you can play it backwards
so we can get my Terminator and my
professor back again
[Music]
yeah
at least For You on YouTube
but I'm left
with a rather child Professor though it
still has a little gray hair and a
rather sad looking Terminator
you can support periodic videos on
patreon your name could appear on our
Periodic Table of patrons which now
hangs in the professor's office and
Neil's lab in fact you could be our
first gallium supporter no one's picked
that one yet